with a Swaney becomes aware but we do
things our what I'm position already
turn off run the main and around and I'm
the pie but we still do things you can
only dream of you're neat I to give a
warm welcome to Detective Ivan Lewis
from internals the problem is the
tactics you employ there's even talk of
baseball bats the problem is the
collateral damage I'll tell you anything
so what do you want to do shut us down
easy jack no means
everybody on the floor
soon institution he has killed and he
will kill again this is our main 18 foot
robbery across Switzerland Italy and
France hydrol Davis very low-key no
trouble hey there sweetheart where is he
where can I find it there is one fat
you're overlooking nothing you got a
wrong man the ramifications of your
careless actions you have severe
repercussions I think I found your weak
point no you felt my glasses you Yuna
suspended pending further investigation
I want a gun on a page this guy's guilty
I'm gonna get it
I thought Georgia products signed a
place known
I'm gonna destroy you
hey Telamon coming after him I'm coming
after all of them